[Music]
oh
can I trust you
of course
trust you
always
eight years ago you two were citadel's
top spies but we were double crossed by
one of our own and your memories were
erased
brought you here because I need your
help I coached Little League
there's my guy
right now every agent around the world
is looking for you too
I think you have the wrong person
you're gonna wish I was dead
[Music]
you remember
everything he was made some games
whoever betrayed us is readying for
something kind of Christmas
are we together I'm flatter yourself
[Music]
unexceptionally skilled at getting
Citadel agents to turn you did this
amazing we can never find out you told
me to trust you why would you trust me
I'm exceedingly untrustworthy I'm a spy
because no one else it's just you and me
everything you know
is a lie
[Music]